so in this section we are going to
discuss about further applications of
read mappings so in the genome there can
be multiple complicated structure
variations like deletions wishes
deletions of a segment in the genome or
insertions that the genome at some
particular positions a new sequence got
inserted or mobile sequence insertions
like reto transpose on alou and tandem
duplications or interspersed application
inversions which is inverse of fragments
in the genome a translocation which move
one fragment from one place to another
place the question is can you use the
approach of mapping to identify these
variations well you remember about read
pair sequences that we discuss in
assembly we have read one read two
separated by a distant in sir sighs it
turns out that grid pairs is very useful
in detecting these structure variations
for example inversions translocations
duplication or trans musician can be
detected using the mapping approach we
met the first read-through the reference
we met a second read to the reference if
we see any changes in directions all the
changes in the distance between the
first read and the second read comparing
to the expected in sir size that is a
signal for detecting the structure
variations but we if we escape from the
genome level let's move to the i na
level so it turned out that rich mapping
can be also we use in discovering the
splice junctions using ionize it so here
intuitively you can
see that you have a read instead of
mapping the read to a one particular
location of the genome the read can be
decomposed into multiple are multiple
parts and each part mapped to different
regions of the genome and of course we
have other applications but it is a good
time that you can go out and talk to
biologists and to understand what
applications can you solve using the BWT
or read mappings approach thank you